and as promised here he is back here on
the rich eisen show in advance of
uh the new animated series hoops that
we'll be
debuting on netflix starting on friday
that's tomorrow he is none other than
rob riggle how are you robert
i'm good buddy good to see you you two
in the flesh this is an animated show
correct this is an animated program
this is an animated show not for the
kids not for the kids
let's be real clear on that okay so uh
let's
start with this right right now off the
back not for the children
nope what so put the kids to bed when
you start streaming hoops
that's right and and if uh aggressive
foul language
uh you know is not your cup of tea which
is totally fair
probably not gonna want to see this one
okay sit this one out but
you know i'll be honest it is my cup of
tea uh even though you know i'm not
allowed to work blue on this program
but you're so you play the father of a
coach
in this series correct map this out for
what for everybody for
for it's row
of great comedic talent all right so uh
uh ben hoffman created it uh
chris miller phil lord executive
producing jake johnson producing
and starring in it as the coach ben his
character's name ben
i play barry hopkins his dad yes i'm a
former pro athlete who now owns a
steakhouse
i make his life hell um i'm always
giving him a hard time i don't respect
him i bust his beans constantly i'm
always judging him
i don't wish him ill though he's my son
i do love him
okay um so that so it's not a
hate-filled thing but it's definitely a
a ball-busting thing
then you've got natasha legero you've
got ron funchess
uh steve berg i mean 80 miles you've got
some of those
great comedians uh cleo kings in it
just great comic talent uh lined up and
it is uh very funny uh
jake johnson is off the charts funny in
it there's a lot of cussing
um uh he plays a high school basketball
coach
in kentucky who uh you know has he's mad
at his wife he's mad at his dad he's mad
at his best friend
uh and he just can't seem to get it
together but he's trying to coach these
kids
uh these high school kids to be winners
even though he's
far from being a winner himself well i
this is great i mean
you named a ton of funny people jake is
as funny as they come he's been on the
show before
first time i ever met him he wore um
this is back when my show was a podcast
in the nfl
he wore an old mike ditka bears sweater
or a buddy he probably more buddy ryan
bears
arrows big bears thing there quite a
cross
yes it was his when he was a kid and it
still fit him
god bless him classic 85 that's classic
85
classic 85. you know circa i guess for
you and your fandom i guess
circa uh marty schottenheimer would have
been just at the beginning or just right
before
no that was probably no that's probably
i can't that's
i know marty was probably with the
browns around yeah i think he was still
with the browns i think i
think we got him around 87 or 88
somewhere in there right around there
well i mean last time we spoke to uh
patrick mahomes is on a rookie contract
now he has all the american dollars that
are in existence
yes he does that was what a i mean
your team is just taking care of
business they signed chris jones too
i mean you're ready to roll in a couple
weeks here i'm telling you
um uh being out in the desert as long as
we've been out in the desert rich it
feels
really good to be at the oasis drinking
of the water
it feels really good um yeah and and
they're they're all so young and so
motivated and so
uh optimistic and they got the they got
the world by the tail uh i i got to play
uh golf with patrick mahomes and travis
kelsey out at the american century golf
tournament in tahoe
grouping okay and they just were so
fun and so lighthearted and so jovial
and again like i said it's cause i got
the world by the tail right now but
um i don't know it just feels like they
just
there's this wonderful optimism that
surrounds them i i sincerely hope that
we are the team of the 20s
i hope that we are the dynasty of the
20s you know that that would make me
a very happy man well annie reed's only
a 62 year old man right now
i mean and mahomes is basically like
although i i don't know if andy reid's
got a
touch of the wilford brimley rest his
soul in him where he's
he looks older than he really is
you know what i mean like he he might
have that sort of
oh yeah the footballs are stressful
being a head coach in the national
football league is very stressful
very stressful although it's like
sitting in a rocking chair with mahomes
what was that
round of golf like uh to walk me through
that oh it was fantastic he
swings the club so hard i i swear i
every time he did it my back hurt
because i was like how are you how about
you getting that kind of torque he would
come off the tee with
irons because if he used a wood he would
something bad would have happened so he
he really the clubhead speed had to be
around 150.
i'm not even kidding it was just nuts
his game was just like mine
we're like 12 handicaps we were you know
we're in the same grouping for a reason
okay
um and uh
it's not special golf you know we we
were chunking we were rolling putts way
past
way short right i was winning through 15
holes
i i had them through 15 and then we came
in the last
16 17 and 18 and that's i should have
known i was playing against mahomes
uh he always comes from behind he always
comes from behind
like the super bowl it does that's what
he did you know the whole post season
the whole everything the texans he
turned you to the texans basically
exactly
and he did he turned it on and i buckled
like a lawn chair i i double double
double
the last three holes and he went on to
win that day so was uh
was was kelsey like locked in two or is
he just like uh
i think he was a little bit out of it i
think he came in third that day
uh that particular day um but
he when he hits a golf ball he catches
it on the ascending blow it's so funny
when we'd say hit it as hard as you can
man
he would just chunk it or put it in the
woods or it was just out of control
if we left him alone he would pipe it uh
no jokes 330
350. get out of here i i swear to you
we're on a par five uh
coming down towards the lake uh it's
actually 16
yes and he probably hit it 360. because
there's a little a little downhill to
help but
it still was monster drives he also
strikes me as a guy probably got into
the swing oil right around the third tee
box you know what i mean like
doesn't matter what time of day you teed
off like right around the third tee box
he was already just getting in there so
you know he's in just in general in life
he's one of the most jovial guys
i love him he's great look i know you
got to run and uh congrats on on the
show hoops
anytime i get an opportunity to have you
on the show and just chit chat i will
take advantage of that
i do want to show you also uh thanks to
the good people of netflix
trying to include me um and they they
made a
a a trading card of me i guess
i don't know if you've seen this i don't
know who this person is if you can i i
would like to
uh uh basically uh object
to this portrayal um no they're not
telling you that's you is it
no this is yes rich eisen trading card
right
there i don't i don't understand um
again
facial hair and why do you have eyes
that look like you just are a deer in a
headlight
they're all good questions there's no
meat on that bone either
i mean it's not nearly uh as
um as uh flattering as i prefer but i'm
gonna go with it i'm just gonna roll
with it
uh yeah do your best they really messed
out on the facial hair because
that gives you a lot of edge yes it does
so if i ever do cameo in this we'll have
to we'll have to talk
okay yeah we'll fix that we'll that will
fix that up
rob great to chat with you you'll be
well we'll see you always good to see
you man take care
that's right it's uh rob regal right
here on the rich eisen show hoops starts
streaming on netflix
tomorrow and that's a friday for all
those scoring at home and put the kids
to bed that's the
fair warning thanks rob see you bud
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here